um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
what is uh
good morning
good afternoon
happy launch day
is that good morning good afternoon
thing that's more of a tim tatman thing
i should have i should have came up with
my own thing before we went live but hey
um rainy day over here on the east coast
for me but that's okay
because we're exploring eternum welcome
to the stream everybody i hear thunder
outside
so uh hopefully my power holds up let's
uh fingers crossed for that
i already see some people in the youtube
chat
being a little angry about this the
server q wait
which sucks that that is a bummer um
i know west coast just kind of opened up
not too long ago
uh but even with east coast
opening up it was still a lot oops i
need uh i need some more wood let's go
back out here
luckily for me my queue wasn't that long
um
just to kind of get in as fast as i
could i just went to whatever
whatever uh server didn't really have
that many people
going to it i didn't really have
one in mind that i wanted to go to so i
just popped into one and there was only
one person in front of me in line and
boom
[Music]
69 watching
so we are still early on in the game
um despite me
getting up and starting at 8 a.m eastern
i am still early i haven't chosen my
faction yet but i believe we're right
around the corner from that
you think i would like fully remember
because the open beta wasn't
that long ago
but i don't remember
oh uh we got everything we needed cool
i hope they fix it tomorrow i really
want to play this game i think
by tomorrow
you might have
an easier time getting it
because just based off what i saw on
social media
i think a lot of people took off work to
play this today
so you have the launch day hype you have
a lot of people who um
who are who are just able to play
and a lot of people who
force themselves to be able to play by
like calling out of work and stuff so i
think tomorrow
you might have
a little less people right away i'm i'm
fully expecting
later today like after like when i go to
like take a break from playing this i'm
fully expecting later today to just not
be able to get back on but who knows
maybe myself with the server i pick
maybe i'll get lucky
take that back yet no oh yeah we have to
craft so we're crafting timber crafting
stone block
cool
got it
all right so of course leather we need
i wish it told me how much i needed
right here instead of having to go back
to the journal i need
four leather did it say that
no i don't think it did
do you see any improvements from the
open beta
well
so far
no so far it feels very much the same
um
but i i didn't really expect much
changes if there are changes it might
have been to some things that i didn't
get a chance to
experience uh in my time with the open
beta but so far it feels pretty much
exactly the same
which is fine to me i mean in the open
beta
from my point of view my time playing
i didn't really experience anything that
i wanted them to change so
completely fine with me we need 10 of
this
you reckon i should buy this today it
seems super fun
let's see let's see let's see
should you buy it today
that's a it's such a hard question now
that like
the rush is probably only gonna get
worse as the day goes on with people
trying to um
get in i think you know like i said
earlier people a lot of people probably
took off work you know you might even
have some people that like
uh stayed out from school to play but
later today there's going to be even
more people
that
are off work
and
got out of school and i think the
servers are just going to
get a little more crowded as the day
goes on
so
that's a tough question to answer at
this point
if you do get it it might be best to
yeah get it and then jump in right now
but even if you do buy it today and
can't play today today
like
you know i think that's okay it's a
bummer but i think it's okay
i might refund it and get it again when
it calms down
my question to you with that
why even refund it then unless you
really need that like was it 40 bucks
or whatever that translates to wherever
you're from if you're gonna buy it
anyway
just keep it
super hard to get a good name on this
game
um
maybe at this point
i've seen a lot of weird and creative
names so far while i was walking around
with me
my character where coming to work my
character my character i i went with two
eyes in it because i wanted reents which
is uh like a character from the witcher
series
i wanted that name
but it was already taken so i just threw
in two eyes to
get past that
well done
your willingness and practicality are
refreshing
even i myself struggle at times with a
sense of resignation
that chess that armor case this is just
the beginning
from now on you can visit me or the town
board and take any tasks you desire
your help will always be needed thank
you
all right i'll come back to you in a
second let me see what was in that chest
see what the chad chad's saying i've
gone down 300 places in two hours
that's crazy i have heard that people
are
decreasing
and going backwards in their spot in
line which is so insane to me
[Music]
like i'm so i'm so sorry for the people
who really want to play and been waiting
super long for this game
and they they like can't get in but
that's the that's the struggle with this
this type of game like it's it's gonna
happen
oh my first uh uncommon thing that's
cool
like these just kind of look like some
black pants
forty dollars geez i got it cheaper on
steam
twenty five dollar equivalent how did
you get it cheaper
you have a point how long have you
played this
and what is something you don't like
about this game so i have played i
played the open beta for a little over
10-ish hours
um
just because i
i couldn't completely devote my whole
weekend to it when it um
came out
while i'm saying that let me run to the
stash
um and one thing i don't like about it
and i've seen a lot of uh debate about
this on the
new world subreddit and even on twitter
in some places
i kind of don't like that there's no
mounts
uh with me my
my history with mmos was like uh world
of warcraft in 2013
and
that game has mounts so i'm just kind of
used to it even playing single-player
uh
mmorpg or not mmorpgs but just rpgs
you know like i'm used to running around
and and hopping on a
uh oh actually let's equip that instead
and then
either we can sell that one but yeah i'm
just used to running around
and then hopping on a horse
and going somewhere that way with this
game there's just a ton of running
around
uh at this at this run speed because
this is you know you that's the speed
you run at all the time this isn't like
your walk speed and you can run faster
so you're running around at this pace
all the time
and
at first it's it's great because it's
like all right you're exploring the
world you're just getting to know places
but
eventually i want to get around a little
faster that is someone else you should
speak with it at least needs a sprint
like that is the sprint
auto sprint
confidence can be abrasive it does not
exceed her skill
she is a master smith
and she is expecting you oh i want to
speak to esteban you'll find artificial
gums near the forge
it is truly that's one thing i think
they changed from the closed beta i
think you
had a walk as default
and then you did shift to run see this
is the walk if you hold
left control
this is the walk speed
and then
this is your your regular run right here
so
you run any faster if you put your
weapons away i don't think so
because i have tried that
i've had my weapons away before so here
we go weapons away
same speed that would be cool though
that would be really cool if you could
put your weapons away and run faster
that would be uh
like even if it was just a tiny bit
but nope even if my weapons are away
[Music]
i wonder if there's some uh some gear
that can possibly make me run a little
faster but maybe not
but so far it seems like amazon how do i
how do i hide you i had you hidden
before how i had you
there we go
it seems like amazon doesn't have any
plans to add them but
maybe in the future when the map is like
bigger expansions or something and you
have way more ground to cover maybe
they'll decide to add them in
could be who knows
yes i hope they add sprints what about
combat and are the quests repetitive um
a little repetitive uh this will be your
first mmo well the thing with mmos is
you're gonna do so much about the fabled
warrior
a lot of quests of just going out to
kill this thing gather this thing and
stuff of that nature so it will get a
little repetitive here and there
um
so if it's kind of like if you're up for
the grind then
this is the game for you because it's
mmos can be a grind a lot of the time
just to level up certain things and get
better gear and all of that stuff so but
this is it like it's not my first mmo
but
it's um
exactly
it's like the second that i'm probably
gonna pour a lot of time into
i suggested eloise send me to broken
alliance with the other settlements but
she refused
why would she refuse that she believes
it's every settlement for itself and she
will not be persuaded otherwise
that being the case we will need extra
blades show me your skill
open this bag of wall smelt it and forge
an iron sword i will i will do that
don't you worry
maybe because the map size is too small
for mounts yup that's that's what i was
um thinking that's what i was mentioning
earlier um
probably just a little too small let's
open up the map for you right now so
this is what we're rocking with it's
pretty big
but
again maybe it is just a little too
small like i'm talking
the last game i was playing was wow and
i was in 2013 a bunch of expansions had
already come out for it
it was a bigger area than this i'm
assuming i was like in my fuzzy memory
so yeah it just might not be big enough
um
i'll get over my my mount thing
like it'll be fine
yeah no problem mr
clean glad to answer all of your
questions
um i've done a decent amount of research
for this game with producing uh
you know leading up to the production of
like the everything we know or
everything you need to know video that's
up on gamespot
youtube channel right now
um
so i know more than
i anticipated on ever knowing about this
game
but i'm in
i'm locked in now
i'm ready to ready to be the best that
there ever was but look at all these
campfires you see all this
this is what happens when a bunch of
players are going through the tutorial
at the same time and just
being forced to build camps in the same
spot
all right let's look for
a boulder with or
i already have some ore and i got that
by accident
and that's not what i need
like i was just looking for a regular
boulder and then came across
the one with ore in it
so if only i could remember where i got
that from
i think it was this way
around more rocks
obviously
around more boulders
but it has a has a different look than
these boulders i'm still kind of walking
up to all of them just to see
yeah nuggies it is it has launched today
today is the first day happy launch day
um oh there is you know
this is not what uh the area i thought
it was gonna be maybe it's this way
it is launch day uh it is a staggered
launch but i think for the most part
it's out in in a lot of the places
already
um eu was first
uh
east
east coast in north america i think was
like second or third which uh which my
coast
west coast just got it not too long ago
so yeah
what are the queue times right now it
depends on
what server you're trying to get into
when i
was
looking at the server list there are no
like boulders with or right here i'm
just looking over the edge for no reason
when i was looking at the server list
valhalla was insane
200 000 over 200 000 waiting
in a queue
to get into valhalla
so
i knew right away that's not where i
wanted to be
um
so it depends on on which
server you're trying to get into i know
a lot of people are trying to get into
certain servers because of the streamers
they like watching and the communities
based around that streamer and they want
to be in their company
aka their guild
uh so it's i guess it's kind of up to
you they might all have a decent weight
at this point i said mine wasn't very
long at all
let me just try a regular boulder and
see what happens
the ore you need is in the heavy satchel
in your inventory
oh
you know
you know max
it would be great if i could read it
would be 100
amazing if i no pharrell thank you
[Laughter]
you're right
i was just in my head i was thinking i
got or like i saw that the number was
already like
like i had already had some so i was
like oh i just need to go back to that
same spot where i got or the first time
i didn't even read the rest of the
sentence
thank you thank you max you saved us
some time
and you reminded me to always read the
full
objective or to pay attention to what
the person is telling me in the
beginning
we got what we need and now reading the
full sentence
craft or
iron ingots
at the smelter so let's build the
smelter
one thing i didn't do in the open beta
but now i have access to one is i didn't
shoot a gun at all and i missed
but now that i have one
i'm definitely gonna use it a little
more
does your progress save across servers
um
what do you mean
by that you can only have one character
on a server at a time
um i don't even know if there's a way to
transfer to a different server
like they give you a bunch of
disclaimers when you're making your
character being like hey if your friends
are playing on a different server
you can't play with them if you pick
this one you better you gotta choose
wisely
so i'm gonna go ahead and say no
it does not carry over because your
character can't carry over
um how many do we need we need nine
whoa
[Music]
wrong thing
you think the game will come to next-gen
consoles probably not
i don't even think there's controller
support
i'm pretty sure there isn't
um
i don't think so
but you never know there's
games being ported constantly
from you know like
playstation to pc and pc to switch and
all of that in between so
never say never
but i also don't think so
[Music]
yes
i should have equipped that
give me that
yes bind it to me
it is mine
all right
where is she back over here oh she was
right next to her all right
ah yes the blade is sleek it is i did a
good job
you could use more polish but i see
potential here thank you thank you i am
glad to have you in monarchs bluffs yes
glad to be here
i strongly believe an alliance between
settlements is essential to battle the
corruption
short of that i will do what i can at
the forge
there anything else i can do for you you
are sharp aren't you
i fear we're also at risk of losing the
loyalty of some right here in monarchs
bluffs
i wonder if you might help me ensure
this does not happen
there is one here whose skill matches my
own and her discipline survivalist
thornton
she is very much a lone wolf and she may
be tempted to leave the pack
all right please speak to her and
convince her to stay
if we start now can we move if friends
start on another doesn't seem like it
um what's your thought so far on the
launch so far
um
and i don't want to you know jinx it you
know knock knock on wood all those
superstitions knocking on my desk um so
far
running great
i haven't run into any like server
issues or any of that there hasn't been
any weird glitches i can't buy that
right now
i haven't run into any weird glitches or
or or lag or anything like that despite
so many people pouring into the game and
i i think that is a testament to amazon
doing that whole staggered launch
as much
criticism as it got i think that helped
a lot with helping
the
server be stable for people
and then uh colin said thoughts so far
i still like it in the mood for
conversation right now
i haven't gotten past where i was in the
open beta but i i still think it's
pretty great um if anything i think i
might like the combat more now
i'm not sure why that is but i've been
having more fun with it
wait a minute gom sent you didn't she
she did she sent
with me if all hell breaks loose and the
forces of corruption march across
eternum i'd rather be out there than in
here
filled up
i'm not going anywhere just yet but it's
nice to know i can
what about you friend
you sure you can hey you know what get
another gun you and gomes want a medal
how about you step up and do a little
hunting head out to the wilds and make
camps
all right so now i'm going to go out and
create one of those camps we've seen
so many of out there
let's add to the fire
and then we get another musket so that's
cool
i like that i'm getting muskets i wonder
if that has to do with the town i'm in
in the open beta
um i got started off over here
and then it took me to ever fall
and then this time i started down here
and
now i'm up here and even though everfall
was cool they look nice
i kind of like monarchs bluffs
way more
i don't know why it's just a nice
looking town maybe it's the blue flags
and stuff everywhere i don't know what
it is
but uh let's go hunt ourselves some
wolves
and why is to make a camp cool
sounds good actually let's go back to
the map real quick where how far is it
it's not too far
i also changed my auto run key because
it by default it's the equal
key i changed it to like the what's it
called the tilde key up by the one
so
that's a little easier to reach
while i'm already running instead of
taking my right hand and pressing equal
all right so
[Music]
let's actually
so we're not going to be in the in the
thick of the fires we're going to build
it right here
bam
do we even have enough supplies for it
yeah we should no
no
no we don't all right we need
one more piece of wood
one more one more
there we go that should be it
hey hey get off my fire dude move
i guess you're gonna finish building it
for me and then you know go for it
also
while we're here
because i saw that we i had some um
what's the difference between energizing
light rashing this one has mana more
mana regen i don't need that
i don't think i'm going to be doing much
magic at all
so
is that all light rations we can make
how much can we make we can make three
three more
let's make three more is this game like
an online witcher i i wish i mean i've
seen so many people compare it to
different types of games
um
i can see why a person would throw which
are out there
it's not a one-to-one comparison but i
can see why um i've seen a lot of people
compare it to greed ball which i own a
copy of and i've never played it though
like which are my top french top
franchise of all time top game witcher 3
number one game of all time these
figures behind me
which are three figures
um i'm i'm obsessed with that world
uh the books the show the comics
everything
um
so i know a lot about that world
but greed fall never played greenfall
and i have seen other people compare it
to say
uh elder scrolls online mixed with
runescape
and i can kind of see that too i haven't
spent a ton of time in runescape
but from the crafting
um
from the amount you can do
with the trade skills i've seen videos
of people comparing
the skills and stuff in runescape and
then putting those logos on top of these
logos and being like see it's like the
same thing they match up so
i think this game oh i thought this was
deeper than that oh
i've i've seen a lot of comparisons i
think this game probably takes a lot of
cues and inspiration from our
plethora of other games
but yeah i think it's a big mix
this game is like world of warcraft it
is in the mmo sense yeah
it has its own differences for one the
active combat system is different from
your world of warcraft which would have
it be an auto attack
and uh like auto dodging and stuff like
that
okay let's go back to sword and shield
i'm not loving shooting the dogs like i
thought i would
thought i was gonna be out here
being all cool and hunting with a musket
now
no
just bought this game and i'm kind of
excited nikki
you should be
especially if you're into mmos i think
i think you're going to enjoy this
were you in any of the betas any of like
the open beta closed beta and stuff
nikki
i'm like skinning these when i don't
need to i just need to defeat them i'm
like doing both i guess it's fine to do
both
ways
yeah shooting them wasn't even like
taking
so hopefully the musket we get from
completing this
will be
stronger
we have so many people over there
forming the walls
doing the same quest
the good thing about this game is
everything kind of just spawns in the
same spot
so
i mean if someone
kills the wolf the local coming right
back like in that same spot and i am
getting too close to dying so let's eat
some food look at that look at him
respawned right back in the same spot
that was quicker than i thought it would
even
all right so
[Music]
we're good on
wolves head back
how long did it take you to get in not
long at all
east coast servers opened at 8 00
am
i slowly rolled out of bed and
opened the game up around nine
i chose
purposely chose a server that
didn't have a lot because it'll show you
how many people are in the
queue um
i purposely sure chose a server that
didn't have a lot of people in its queue
because i just didn't really have a
preference
and
there was only one person in front of me
once i like had gone through the intro
made my character
there's only one person so it took me
three maybe five minutes to pop in
the feet snaggletooth wolf and collect
the sharp wolf fang
so these different types of wolves yes
they are damn
i also forget what the colors mean the
damage colors that are popping up
like shows
what the um
what they're like resist if they're
resistance or they're weak to that
attack type
and i don't remember what orange is
when i hit him with the sword though
pretty much all coming out white which
is just normal
normal ass
damage
are there raids in this or live world
events like in destiny
there are i believe the raids are just
called expeditions in this game they are
a five like a you you go with a party of
three to five
um into a dungeon and you fight bosses
and mini bosses and do
solve puzzles and riddles and get
special loot so pretty much a raid
if you ask me but there are also
um world events in the
sense that there are like wars that
happen so
there's none taken over right now but
each territory here each section of the
map can kind of be owned
by one of the factions
so you'll have like
wars being initiated over control of the
territory and stuff and you'll be
fighting with your faction to uh
completely take it over
i need two more of those
wolves
what server am i on over there on the
twitch chat i am on the north east
server in the toe toe pan topan
something like that
it's like i think yeah i think it's
t-o-p-a-n
it's been a while since i like chose it
i don't even remember
and it's going good it is going good
i guess the guy doesn't see the twitch
chat no i have it open too it's just for
the longest time there was nothing
happening over there but i see i see you
guys over there
i see you friends over there don't worry
i'm sorry for just like walking in
circles right now i am looking for more
wolves though so
i guess i'm not being completely
unproductive
there they are you know this guy is just
completely trying to kill them before me
ah did i not did that not count
get over here before they come get you
i like rarely use my heavy attack i need
to start using that more
[Music]
can you quest as a team i missed that
one by dead man's bones uh i'm pretty
sure yeah i think so
i'm so much of a lone wolf
that
i have not played with anyone yet
graphics look sucks suspect
on my end they look pretty good it's not
the most beautiful game in the world
but i think it looks pretty nice
[Music]
all right what am i doing
along here do i have to actually slice
it open
what is this game even it is an mmorpg
called new world from amazon studios
um
if you don't know what uh mmorpg means
it is massively multiplayer online
role-playing game
i think your world of warcraft's in your
final fantasy 14s and stuff okay i see
what i've been doing wrong
you know chad here here's the thing
here's the thing
i don't go live that often
not on like my own channels and stuff
so if you see me get a little turned
around
and like forgetting or not figuring out
100 what i need to do like right away
it's because
i'm trying to oh perfect i don't have to
kill another one i could just open this
one i am trying to talk to you guys uh
answer all your questions and also
progress here at the same time cool we
didn't have to kill anymore because i
guess those that either someone else
left or i left were just like hanging
out there so that's good
good job amazon yeah you could say that
especially considering
this game was announced with like
crucible and
some other i forget the other name of
the other game
but two games that got cancelled
basically and this is the game that
survived
so
i'm i'm looking at it at a i hope it
succeeds just because of that just
because the other games were
you know just
dead on arrival pretty much um
so i'm rooting for this one even if i
don't stick around for a long time i'm
rooting for this game to have like a
call follow-up to those wolf guns have
you you're tougher than you look
all right you made your point
not like i really wanted to leave the
settlement anyways
for more than a decade you know
even when you're roaming about it's nice
to think you have somewhere to go back
to
word i filled out i will
but i can't say magistrate biggsford
does much to inspire confidence around
here hey he's a strange bird he's a
stranger and with this corruption
bearing down on us we need him to be
sharp
don't we all though i don't know
bixbit's decent enough just weird
you're so eager to help and you should
go check in
make sure he's keeping focused if you
catch my drift i have nothing else to do
i was shipwrecked on this island you
know
i don't know my backstory do i have a
family in the place that we left who
knows
but here i am on this island i might as
well make friends with everyone right
you're eager to help
i gotta get in good with everyone
this will be dead too
well
we'll see about that
you world that's funny what is new world
on it is on pc i see another comment up
there from tripp foxworth that asked if
it's coming to
uh console i don't think so
i don't think so at all
how beta does this game feel so far
i mean are you asking
just like how it feels so far feels
pretty it feels pretty great
um i'm waiting on the west coast server
and have been waiting for an hour and a
half now with 5k people in front of me
no
what server are you trying to get into
oh my goodness ah just the one i was
looking for i see you flitting about
town getting to know everyone it's
exactly what i was hoping for
good
i've been thinking about how best to
defend monarchs bluffs against
corruption
i think we can ill afford to pretend the
situation is not dire
so how best to do that
here we go
the syndicate and the covenant right
whether we want to admit it or not
they're the ones best suited to defend
monarchs bluffs right then
we should talk to them
indeed
and we should welcome their presence
here
you should speak with representatives
from each faction i will and then choose
to which you will pledge your allegiance
i will i will speak to all of them
um in the open beta
i chose
purple and purple one purple one
syndicate
in this one i'm trying to figure out if
i want to switch it up
i don't know i don't know yet
give me one second let me see something
[Music]
all right
to speak with them i kind of want to go
with the um
marauders this time
what's level cap
i don't remember
out of everything to not remember i
don't remember
100
90
no
oh whoops i was trying to like talk to
someone else you seek the glory and
riches of battle yeah you possess a
fortitude you may become one of us oh
tell me more we are the solution to a
world in chaos
through strength discipline and
perseverance we will enforce our will
and bring this land to order
right
so the marauders are basically the
military faction and they want to
free the land
let's go let's see who's next
[Music]
looks like we got a lot of
marauders here or maybe they're just
over here because that's he's up there
i haven't really seen any
other factions lately but maybe i will
once i come down here
a couple of them right here
this is right next to them so this one's
the more religious faction i'm surprised
it's not in a church last time it was in
a church so they're uh
trying to get rid of the heretics on the
island covenant shares its light with
all
so as to lead all men from darkness
will you carry the light with us
tell me in all people there is a spark
an initiative if you will
in some people it burns so brightly that
others feel it
we in the covenant are the purveyors of
the spark
we foster its growth in all people
we protect the light
interesting
interesting thank you i'll uh i'll take
that all into account um
i just have some more people to go speak
to i'll come right back to you
all right let's go find the syndicate
who are the more secretive faction
the ones who are more focused on
knowledge
instead of
being all about
that warfare
like obviously you know they got to
fight they got to bring they gotta put
up arms and
you know slice and shoot some fools but
they're about the knowledge look at him
look at him reading look at him
wish to learn the secrets that only the
syndicate have uncovered don't you
anymore why we are the learned ones we
use the razor of logic and the guide of
reason to understand our world
we possess forbidden knowledge and we
wield the power of this knowledge just
as logic dictates
right
[Music]
spoken to them all
it's between syndicate
and marauders for me
speak with the factions they're the ones
best suited to defend the
settlement will do
no i think so
as rowdy and demanding as they can
sometimes be
they are effective
if you want to make a difference here or
anywhere in eterna
it's really the most efficient way to do
so
okay
so now i have to pick one
who do i want
like i said covenant
we're not going with the covenant i
don't know i'm just not feeling them
um so chat
which do i want to go
which one which one do i want to go to
why would you play an mmo with a
controller
yeah i
personally
i can't
think of a time when i would want to
play with a controller but
okay
everybody has their own thing
at this point i don't i can't picture me
going back to playing um a shooter with
a controller even though i did just by
death loop on ps5 but that's beside the
point like call of duty and like halo
i'm going to be playing on pc mouse and
keyboard
so we have one marauders
we have another marauders
no same marauders
they're the chads we got another
marauders another marauders a syndicate
another marauders
another marauders
john is going covenant listen that's
fine if you're going covenant i
go for it i just i don't know they don't
they don't speak to me so
whether it was the open beta or even
this one so i'm not even gonna
mess around with it we got a lot of
people saying marauders we only have one
syndicate so
i think we're gonna go marauders
i think i'm gonna like uh
all of you choose my fate
green gang
what i was what i was thinking about in
the open beta
was
grand theft auto san andreas
and the
like grove street versus the ballers
grove street was green
and for some reason i forgot about that
and that's why i picked
the purple uh my big syndicate last time
but uh
yeah i was just like what uh what what
was grove street let me pledge my
alliance to whatever grove street would
be
so
[Music]
here we go
here pressure gang let's go
is this game on ps5 nah not on ps5
[Music]
in the kit all day i like them both and
listen here's here's the thing chad
here's the thing yes i'm gonna let the
peer pressure of you guys saying go
marauders
to get to me right now i was kind of
leaning that way anyway since i had done
syndicate in the open beta but
you get to change
your faction every 120 days
so i can jump ship if i really want to
that's the upright posture of a proud
warrior let's do it i'm ready to accept
your allegiance why join a faction
we're going to skip all of this i
already know all of this if you want to
know
some of it
i'm sorry
but we're just jumping right in
so here's here we we still get that
choice again just in case we want to
change our minds
yep pc only pc only
boom marauders proud warriors who fight
with honor for glory and
self-improvement
through conflict one grows in strength
and skill
there it is
120 days
lock it in
level nine green gang let's go if you're
serious about the marauders i have a
challenge to offer you
i am serious about the marauders i just
like pledged my life to you
what more do you want some of the most
savage in the region
we often hone our combat skills by
practicing them
yes cool test your metal if we deal
fishing
oh i forgot you get uh you could die
from
doing like the first quest
i totally forgot about that because last
time
i finished it and got purple dye
and
was like trying the purple dye on
everything
and then someone in the chat had
mentioned like you know put my gloves
purple and it looked like i had thanos
hands and
amazing amazing so now i could just be
the hulk
alright so let's go
and purge this fishery
purge the fishery can we get out this
way yes we can
on that auto run real quick
got some got some g fuel with us because
we're real gamers we are not sponsored
not at all
not even a little bit
it's just the coffee wasn't doing it for
me this morning i don't know why
i do coffee more often than like an
energy drink like that but the coffee
wasn't
wasn't him right this morning
how far is this we're finally at the
point now that we've chosen a faction
um based on my time in the open beta
this is when a lot of quests are much
further away
so this is where you'll see me walking
way more often
so we need to get over
there okay there is a path over this way
all right
let's see
i'll protect you in game with my life
thank you jonathan
i'll wait until i'll wait six months
until the open beta ends
okay
[Laughter]
i totally get being skeptical
wait people unironically drink g-fuel i
started drinking g-fuel ironically as a
joke it was gonna be like content for
like my personal channel
um
just to be like
look at me i'm a real gamer i'm drinking
g-fuel
and the first flavor i tried was um
raging gummy fish
and i really liked it
so lo and behold here we are with me
still buying it
i think i've only bought it twice again
after that um
but yeah i i do like it i this is the
only flavor i really like
i don't walk around repping it all the
time and with t-shirts and stuff like
that because again i'm just not
sponsored
um
but i do really like it
the tetris flavor that came with this
cup
not good though in my opinion
so far i only really love one flavor and
like i said majority of the time
i'm a coffee guy
if i'm if i need my caffeine fix i'm
usually going to coffee
it's been an hour and i'm at 214 in the
queue popular game it is it's way more
popular than i thought it would be today
honestly i knew it would be popular but
like
the amount of concurrent players on
steam and the amount of people on twitch
even streaming and watching it
insane
but
hoping the blue is definitely and i see
down arrows on it the blue is definitely
means
he was resistant to those gunshots
so he's probably more
weakened by like uh slash damage and
thrust
[Music]
i was about to say
did that move not actually hit him
better than eso not sure
i haven't put a lot of time in it yes so
i think i did maybe one free trial
of esl and then kind of
whenever i i tried to play eso it made
me just want to play regular ass
single-player
um
elder scrolls
so i never
really
got deep into it i was always just like
uh you know i'd rather just go play
skyrim or something
definitely not the right attitude to
have about it
maybe i should have given it more of a
chance but
oh well
there's so many games to play you know
you can't you can't play
especially when it comes to animals
you can try but eventually you're you're
gonna fall off
a
i don't think there's anyone out there
that just all of them stick and they
somehow play all of them at the same
time
if i could clone myself
and just have one of my clones play
certain games
then i would
100 probably be into like eso and all of
that
but unfortunately let's try the musket
again
actually while there's no one around us
let's try the other musket i have two
other ones damn
yeah this one's much better let's pop
that in instead
still
getting blue so clearly that's not the
right type of damage for him
oh wrong wrong button up wrong button
let's see some food
you have to toggle pvp yes you do have
to
toggle and flag yourself for pvp
um you can do that after you join a
faction so now i can do that if i really
wanted to
i've never been a big pvp guy i'm
probably going to try it out you know
once or twice just to
say i did whoops
but um
yeah that has to be toggled on in a
settlement so i can't even do it right
now even if i wanted
indoors
sucks
someone earlier asked me if there's like
something i don't like
fighting in like a closed space like
this
a little shack
sucks camera wise
i don't know if you guys can hear my dog
spazzing at the door
probably no one at the door at all
right just our neighbor like slamming
their door too loud
hey shush
there's no one there no one's bothering
that prone dodge from the gods
there you go that's that's a good way to
put it i didn't hit the wrong button
that was just a
strategic move to get away from
that enemy
i have six attribute points we gotta
take care of that once we're done with
this
three
two more did i get one in here
yeah i just heard like a door
slam is very different
but not the one that was in here
oh hello
excuse me sir i was just trying to see
what was underneath
the thing
coming
up here did i check this one already no
i didn't
i only got a gpu it only took six months
oh man
i've been like
looking at my pc and thinking
hey maybe i should uh upgrade
some parts
it does look like it's
right now specifically
find what you need
but i'm glad you got one
all right this last one
boom
boom
let's go talk to roger again
[Music]
get out this area
and then
take care of some attribute points whoa
hey i'm leaving all right relax
i don't need any of that
i only play single player or pvp in eso
that's probably what i would do too i
probably wouldn't
be playing
oh yeah that was where i was supposed to
go
and now i'm pretty sure that's how i'm
gonna play this game
it's just it's just how i get down
and sometimes i want to be more
involved in a bigger community
especially in a game like this but
with that comes the demands of like
playing at a certain time i always feel
like and it's just like hey we're gonna
do this raid or this expedition right
now you know like
be online now but it's like ah but i
really want to play
hot wheels unleashed i'm just throwing
that title out there it's not even out
yet but yo
i'm seeing good reviews i was gonna get
it anyway but
but that's that's always my thing i have
so many interests that like i like to
play games like this
in that
in that like single-player way
let's see
one second while i auto run up this hill
[Music]
so
all right what's going on in the church
solo mmo
rpg is the vibes
i didn't realize that that many people
uh we're down with playing a solo
sometimes i feel like oh man i'm the
only
only person that just wants to like keep
to myself and run around by myself in
the game
but that's cool that's cool to know
other people uh
do the same
what's the game about story wise
oh all hail jeff bezos
okay so the story is you are on
eternum
that is this island here
you're on a tournament you have uh
washed up ashore there was a storm and
you shipwrecked
on this island that is full of a magical
source called azoth azoth
i've seen a couple different
pronunciations
and
basically you're just
here you know just to like make your
mark on this world and and join a
faction and kind of just like control
different areas and keep the corruption
at bay and figure out what happened to
the ancients because the ancients are
kind of what started the corruption
in the first place through their
experimentation with the the azoth
um
azoth is also known for like eternal
life so a lot of the enemies a lot of
adventurers before you came here looking
for the substance for eternal life and
came here just to lose their soul
um
you know it's kind of like a gift and a
curse like you know some people got
great power or some people got corrupted
some people
lost their soul and are now zombies that
i've you've been seeing me kill
um
so there's a lot of crazy like weird
lore things going on but there's also a
lot of just like secrets and things that
like you're gonna uncover as you play
through the game um those expeditions
slash
raids are really lore heavy so learn a
lot through those apparently
from now on you will carry yourself as a
true warrior as a marauder
it's a marauder thank you
we are strongest than initiated let us
endeavor to bring victory to the
marauders
yeah so i see
uh some questions in the chat i see
you're
you're answering them as well yes you
can sheath it let me show you
boom
it's a way you just press x
if that that's the default to put it
away
and
um fast travel you can
um can i fast travel to anywhere yet
uh
well one you can recall to the inn oh
this will show you here too so let's say
i was outside of town you can recall to
the inn but there's a cool down of 60
minutes if you recall to the end but
then there's also fast travel which you
use the azoth which i was talking about
earlier
um that little magical blue substance
um you can use that to fast travel
around as well
the cost of it depends on how far you're
going and how much you're holding so
depending on how encumbered you are it
will cost more
as off
i think this guy's fast traveling right
there
yep
bye
[Music]
um actually let's go back to him and
open up the
faction mission so with with the
factions you get
different quests pick this up too
because you get
some things from that
[Music]
let's see
you know the game is boss when you can
cheat
yup that's the killer feature of this
game
putting away your weapon
okay let's see
all right so after this we'll deal with
our attribute points because i totally
forgot about that and just jumped right
back into this
so
we can do
one of these things i've identified a
threat to marauder interests go to the
minds of deb mcglot and defeat every
withered
sure
let's do it
let's do it
um but first let's open up that
character menu we've got six
points to play with
um if you didn't know
there's no traditional class
class class system in this game so
you're kind of just specking out
the way you want to play
in this screen and a little bit over
here in weapon mastery
so um
we are going to
put strength up
a little more go to 15.
[Music]
uh this dexterity helps with this as
well
yeah i'm gonna do dexterity a little bit
too
let's do that to 12 through constitution
under 12. let's do them both to
13.
constitution is just our overall health
commit and you can respect for free up
to level
20.
i think he used to say it down here but
now it doesn't but
so i've mainly been using sword and
shield so i've just been leveling up my
weapon mastery in that i think next we
will switch to the rapier
because i kind of like how
how it played when i was uh playing the
open beta and then there's the musket
which i didn't use that much
but like come on
they could have given me that a little
bit come on oh they need to close it all
the way
so let's see whirling blade causes five
rent for 10 seconds
i actually think i wanted this
next
actually not yet i barely use heavy
attack
[Music]
i need more physical armor
let's do it
um and then we have some territory
standing points
so let's spend those two while we're
here
these are
buffs for your character while you're in
a specific territory
um i usually just kind of if it's here i
usually just default to the extra xp
gain while you're in a territory
um maybe one of the other three will pop
up with that
decrease crafting fee increase storage i
don't think we need these two yet so i'm
gonna go with that
um earn more territory standing
crafting feed down again
gathering speed let's do that one this
time
and xp gain so
no brainer let's go with that
word
we've done all our menu fun
now let's go do something else actually
i'm lying we didn't do all our menu fun
oh hello hello
oh i get titles got it
that's fun hang on
so there's one that says only play solo
no voice chat doesn't duel
that's cool let's do only play solo
uh that might change in the future but
for now let's let everybody know
uh
i wanted to go to
my inventory i'm in the wrong menu
here we go
[Music]
all right so you i don't want you don't
want you
i feel like everything i haven't really
gotten any great
oh cool got some new gloves though
staying there staying there
you weren't wearing gloves at all before
actually what what am i doing why am i
not wearing this hot
like it's
not what i want him to look like but
that's cool
so here's a secret that i didn't know
for a while
oh hang on we got a question about
titles so apparently
the titles come from achievements i
didn't know that until just now but it
looks like
uh you get them through
these
achievements
so say for joining the marauders i got
three titles
and then it looks like
yeah you can see some of them here
it'll show you like what you get
for those that's cool
so right now since i'm doing
sword and shield
sword and shield even have one oh did i
already get it yeah i already got it i
wonder if it came with a
oh i guess i got to get to level 20. if
i get to oh level 10 too so level 10 i
guess sword expert and then blade master
which is kind of cool
so yeah achievements will get you
new titles and then you can just come to
bio
and change them here
uh oh yeah what i was about to say i
didn't know this
in
open beta
until like the very end of open beta or
something like that but if you want to
like
beep something but have it not visible
it is just right here in chain skin
and then you can scroll all the way down
to hide headgear
or i can just like change the way it
looks but i think everything else is
locked for me yeah
so hide headgear confirm
so a little different than other games
that i've played that like
kind of has a more upfront
um can you accept multiple missions yeah
if so
there were multiple missions for the
same mine you were going to really
taylor saving me time
that is another reason why like i was
like oh i kind of want mounts because i
was like running back and forth so much
so if i can
save time and pay attention to where
things are so go to the mines did you
see another one here
oh i never even noticed this so this is
pvp down here
and then pve up here last time i didn't
know so interesting
so yeah this is go to
something's anger and this
oh i see there are at the mines got it
boom so yeah two in progression right
now and they're in the same area
thank you
taylor
everybody clap clap it up for taylor
right now
all right if you if you have your hands
free right now you know you're not
watching this stream while you're
driving clap it up for taylor
don't watch the stream while you're
driving please don't
please don't if you're watching while
you're driving pull over right now
turn off your car throw the key out the
window
you don't you don't deserve a car
dm me on twitter give me your car
you don't deserve it
the game does need mounts says zero in
the chat
it does but
i think it'll i think it'll happen i
think in the future
we'll probably get it
you know they don't want to give you
everything right away
they want people to like not be playing
and then
pop up with like a blog post
just being like hey new update mounts
come back and play
strategically drop it when their numbers
drop just be like hey
you can have pets and mounts
get over here
check this game out
you can have pets and if you can name
your mouth and stuff like that you know
guaranteed it's you know mine will be
called bezos
you have three basils
that give me your car
yes i did yes i did are you are you one
of the ones that are driving
reginald because if so
give me your card
what kind is it
i might i should have asked that first
what if you're operating a plane
pull over on the nearest cloud right now
and and throw the key out the window and
just park on that cloud all right
you don't deserve that plane either all
right i'm gonna have to confiscate that
plane
i'm in the tesla it goes zoom zoom no
hands required
the teslas have uh have twitch on there
as like an app on the on the screen can
can tesla's run new world
let me know in the chat can tesla's run
new world
how long is the server wait if you're on
a test if you're in a tesla playing new
world
this this guy is just gonna like kill
everything that i'm supposed to be
killing
i think so after this guy's dead let's
jump in and switch to the right y'all
because i want to mess around with it
again
you know it's probably not as powerful
as that uncommon
sword that i was just using
no don't fall don't fall
good job
is there a dab you know
in this in the game i don't think so i
don't even know how to emote
it's a good question
last time i used
this sword i had um like a pirate hat so
i
really felt like
a pirate is like a captain's hat
um search chests
i gotta keep on the lookout for some
chests
there it is
they don't seem as dangerous as the
enemies don't seem as dangerous as i was
hoping i think it's because i'm still
pretty early on
um i'm pretty sure
if you know once you get
further in different areas and stuff
there's
there's multiple types of enemies like
you have the corrupted the lost the
um angry earth and the ancients
so right now you're kind of just seeing
me fight the lost
so i think that
that helps
that probably means that other enemy
types are a little more fierce
than the lost are you know they're just
you know brain dead
soulless zombies type enemies
what is this ice thing i guess that's
for uh
someone with a
can't wait to buy this game at 50 off in
one or two months
hey i mean if you want to wait that long
it probably will
i've gone on sale soonish or whatever
but i mean i don't i think 40
is a
great price for this 40 bucks and no
monthly subscription come on
that's pretty that's pretty dope if you
ask me also p for emote
oh look at that
all right
we have some premium ones too
that's cool
thank you
who said that in the chat oh no
he doesn't want me to emote he doesn't
want me to say anything
i'm sorry i'm so sorry
i didn't mean to i didn't mean to fist
bump in your house
mastery gone up
one of these at one point i gotta try
one of these heavy ass
uh hammers as well like that guy was
using
can i break this open does this give me
[ __ ] i need to be mining skill 100
god damn
where are we at right now
i'm gonna get like beat up while i'm
doing this
uh who's next to me there's someone next
to me okay i think it's a person mining
skill level three
we're almost there we're almost there
100 is right around the corner
right around the corner
40 bucks plus cash shop for convenience
what do you mean are you are you one of
those play to win people
you want those pay to win
i haven't seen much of that
in the game but if if it's there and i
just
haven't paid attention to it and
you know
sorry
is this any good or is it just crap um
what if it's in the middle
what if i tell you it's like in the
middle how does that make you feel
i think it's good i'm having fun with it
i don't think it's crap
um
as i've said a couple times already i
just think
no mounts is a little lame
but at the same time
i think they're gonna come in the future
whether amazon knows it or not
they're gonna they're gonna toss it in
once the map gets bigger
all right so
i want to switch back to the sword i had
oh wait we got better rapier hold up
hold up
did we just get that from one of those
uh
supply crates or something
still isn't really hurting
these ones with the
[Applause]
stinky smoke around them
it's not really
hurting them as much as i wanted to
backup
stamina
yeah yeah stop turning your tracks yeah
i'm not the best everyone i'm not the
best at combat but i do find it oddly
satisfying while it's not the most
it's not the most uh
crazy and detailed and robust
combat system
but i enjoy it let's switch back
to the great sword real quick wrong
button wrong button again here we go
so that we can use our shield
to help
some of their hits
[Music]
it's like with the rapier it's still a
one-handed weapon you think you would be
able to like pop off a shield as well
even though you know it's on it's on my
but
back
can't do that
all right so we need to find more chess
why do i feel like another one is up
here
how did that hit
oh
musket hurt that guy a decent amount
okay there is a chest up here
i'm out of my way dude i know we're in
the same fashion get out of my way
this guy this guy's
has a funny name lunch tray i liked his
name i've been seeing him a lot
since the uh like very first starter
area
so
okay now it's blue again what part of
the body do i have to hit you i feel
like a shot i feel like i shot him in
the house and even and i heard him maybe
it was because his back was turned maybe
no all right headshot
headshot hurts a little
more huh
all right we need more
chests more chest more chest more dress
more chest more chest here we go
we need two more
teleport discounts what are we talking
about teleport discounts
oh for
like some of the micro transactions
i don't really know like what the what
micro transactions they're on the game i
have that that's a portion of games oh
there's there's another one over here i
guess they respawn
all right let me handle you first
unless you fall off the map all right
let's get this and then i think maybe
i'll try to dip into a
micro transaction thing
like a storefront
[Music]
because i haven't really paid any
attention to that but like
are there weapons there i think it's all
cosmetic
like just from looking at the storefront
without going in it was armor
so
well i guess that's not just all
cosmetic because that does
you know armor is going to make it so
that you can
take more hits so if you're buying
really
rare armor
and then going into pvp that wasn't too
smart but that didn't take up too much
health for me so
it was fine
i'm gonna look at that right when we get
out of this area
skins and emotes
see that's what i thought
skins and emotes
do you need good specs to run this game
i would say
um
i'm sure it's on that that site like can
i run this.com or something like that i
haven't been on that site in a minute
um i'm pretty sure you could probably go
there and try to figure out
uh
if your computer can run this but right
now i'm running it on
um
and nvidia 2060
i have 16 gigs of ram
like an amd ryzen
7 something like that
so i don't have like the most
crazy specked out pc
um it's only been a year
like august made a year of me being a pc
player before then i was like
all console and i use max primarily all
the time so i went with a pre-build
hp omen pre-bill
hp omen 30 l
which right after i bought it the 30
series of graphics cards got announced
and then the these pre-build started
shipping with those cards in them so
i asked up i should have waited a little
bit longer but how was i supposed to
know
um
so yeah i would consider this like a
very starter pc um and i bought it
because it seemed like it was very
upgradable easy to open and stuff like
that i felt like it was a good starting
point for me
um and it runs this game just fine all
my settings are on high right now
uh i don't know how crazy it would be if
i kicked it up past high
but i'm streaming and obs is retail
resource intensive so
i won't try it right now
at the risk of the game crashing and
kicking out we are strongest together
let us endeavor to bring victory
completed
completed
and i unlocked an achievement
awesome all right so while we're here
let's duck into this corner over here
and look at the store
because we got a lot of you talking
about
micro transactions and stuff
so let's take a look
we have featured deals so right up front
we have some really shiny armor with an
ugly helmet and then we have weapon skin
i think that's crucial
for a lot of like
people who are hating right now to look
at weapons skin
so it's not
the weapon itself it's not gonna change
how strong it is or anything like that
it's just how it looks
um
so consumables are die again cosmetic
emotes
have nothing to do with like winning as
either
um
and then we have armor skins
which
earlier when i was mentioning
buying different types of armor again i
wasn't even thinking yeah it's just the
skin you're just changing how it looks
weapon skin
housing items
um
company crest so the emblem you can make
for your company or your guild
and then bundles of those things so as
you can see
i i don't get why i've been seeing pay
to win
i don't get it
there's nothing in here
that tells me
i can
pay to
[Music]
to win is it is it somewhere else
wear them xp boosters at
okay so that's what people are talking
about we're talking about xp boosters
over in the the twist chat the true end
game is fashion facts
if you go on their youtube channel the
new new world youtube channel they have
a a fashion show video
of just characters walking down a little
fake runway in the game showing off
their outfits
nothing yet but boosters will be coming
okay interesting
so i think
i think that's a conversation
that
is definitely to be had when the
boosters come
but
i still don't know if that really
categorize can go in the category of pay
to win
over in twitch number sucks ass what
other chat is he reading we're live on
youtube as well
thank you robot mayo we are live on
youtube and twitch
so i'm going back and forth between the
chats
so
hello to one side hello to the other
side
what up
xp boost on mmo is common thing
i think so too
i i don't like again my mmo experience
isn't like huge
but like
especially when
um
expansion packs come out
um
can't you just like buy the expansion
and level up to whatever level you need
to be to play that expansion
like isn't that a thing i wouldn't
necessarily call that
pay to win
because also with an xp boost depending
on what it is what it's for
like i'm just assuming for your
character xp boost
doesn't necessarily mean your weapon is
any better but maybe
there's weapon xp as well
bro how the different classes well there
are no classes not in the traditional
sense
let me duck back in here for you you
have attributes that you
in the way the way you spec out
the this screen will kind of
lean into what way you want to play
um
so
for me i know i'm going to be mainly
like sword and shield
maybe from time to time i'll be like
rapier and musket so i'm gonna lean
heavily into strength and dexterity with
some um
constitution in there as well whereas if
you're a playstyle if you're looking to
be more of like a magic or healer or
something maybe you'll be more in
intelligence and focus because that's
where like the life staff is that's
where the fire and ice staff and stuff
are so
you do that and then also over here you
want to spec out your weapons through
weapon mastery so i also see someone in
the chat saying
what level you get your musket so right
now
because i haven't used it that much it's
only level two so i i've upgraded i've
up leveled it once
and i have a point to spend so while
we're in here let's do that
we can get power shot
we can get trapper oh throw a trap that
lasts for 20 seconds cool
so that doesn't even have anything to do
with my gun i can throw a trap that
would be nice
for uh some of the hunting stuff um
overload musket with gun power causing
the next shot to deal
150 percent weapon damage does not stack
or combine with other
overload shots let's do that
that sounds fun
um and then the most i've played with is
sword and shield so i'm level five over
here i've done a couple
upgrades here
and then the rapier i've only done once
um so what do i have i have an evade
which is cool a small side step so
different than the dodge move that we
already have by default
blurry
i think i want flurry though
since we kind of already have a dodge
move so i don't think that's like
essential right now
so let's do that and if i change my mind
respect for free
at least for right now up to like level
20 ish i think
xp boosts are fine as long as the non xp
the non-boosted experience isn't awful
final fantasy 14 lets you just buy up to
max level 10 which is fine since
leveling doesn't take that long okay
good to know
i haven't put any time into final
fantasy 14.
us east or west i am east and then uh
another question is is the server stable
it's been very stable for me so far
since i've been on i've been on since
8 a.m this morning
or 9 a.m this morning and it is now 1 32
in the afternoon so i would say very
stable i haven't had lag or anything
like that
um but over on the twitch chat got down
to number 13 in the queue and got
disconnected lol
i'm glad you can laugh about it because
just reading that i i felt your pain i i
wanna i wanna drop i wanna drop a tear
for you all right everybody poor pour
out some
some uh some g fuel
in the chat for
for wiki wild over in twitch
but remember everyone
no matter what type of caffeinated drink
you're drinking coffee red bull monster
g fuel always stay hydrated all right so
i have this big thing over here filled
with water
because you always got to stay hydrated
especially if you're playing an mmo you
know if you're playing an mmo make sure
you got your water make sure you got
your snacks make sure you got a p bucket
i'm kidding about the last one
unless unless that's how you live your
life i'm not going to judge you but uh
keep it to yourself
i'm just putting all of this stuff over
here
for the time being i don't really know
what i want to do with a lot of it
um shift and click instead of dragging i
don't know what i want to do with it yet
so i'm just tossing it over here
i'll probably sell it maybe
um
salvage a lot of it let's keep these
three
get rid of you guys you are better so
we're gonna put you on
uh
arrows we don't need arrows because we
just got rid of
other
stuff mods interesting we should
probably take a look at that i haven't
done anything with the craft mods before
um in the open beta
coffee is my choice in lots of water
coffee i just love it love it
would you say
maybe i'm a little addicted to coffee
maybe but i don't i don't usually have
like if i have two cups in a day it's
kind of rare
for me i try to keep it out a little bit
and i have like a hard cut off around
like two ish three o'clock
so i can sleep at night
let's
mess with this dye a little bit
so we got our green dye because we green
gang gang gang
no
not loving it
on the shirt not loving it on the shirt
so let's get rid of it
i like it better as just the buttons
like keeping it white and just having it
be like that extra over there
what about giving us some hulk hands
i literally i look like one of those
kids like the kids toy the the big hulk
hands
i might keep it i don't know why i like
coloring the gloves only and just being
thanos or or the hulk
but i might keep that hold up
let's try the hat
oh i forgot i have the hat hidden which
which is weird when you have the hat
hidden
but then you come into the like the die
armor screen
the hair kind of phases through it maybe
it's just this hairstyle that i'm
rocking but it it's like why does the
hat even show up
let's make
our pants green
i don't hate it
honestly they're ugly as hell but i
don't hate it
i might keep that too
oh
[Music]
buttons okay i wish like once you get a
die you can just like use it oh
what about green shield how's that
looking not bad not bad
all right i think
he barely looks like hulk hands it looks
like gardener hands
okay let's see over here in the chat
let's get rid of this user
i let myself limit myself to two cups of
coffee that is
good that is good
any serious bugs that you've seen nope
[Music]
nope nope nope no serious bugs yet not
on my end
we're rocking with the green hands yeah
rocking with the green hands
let's do it
um talk to talk to who talk to this
person over here
urbana's bigfoot
whoa where did he get the the like loser
thing j dilla tv where'd you where'd you
get that hey hey where hey where hey
where'd you get that
i want that
um
no down here what if i walk right past
you
mr goodbar hd
ah i was wondering when you'd stop by
and say hello again
i hear good things about the work you
and your new allies have been doing
keep it up
so what is not in this what is not in
the game
looks like a complete package on the
surface
everything everything is pretty much in
this game except for mounts i hate just
talking about mounts but it's the only
thing
that's not here i hate saying it but
i got it
um
listen to me uh in the youtube chat i
have already beaten this game
no spoilers but on a scale of one to ten
how was the end game let me know
let me know
john over here is calling cap
on listen to me
listen john i
i think listen to me why would he lie to
us
all right
why would he be capping in the youtube
chat
yeah catmaster
level 10
is a special place double digits
we've unlocked
duels yes you understand
that's why we have to protect this
settlement whatever it takes
whatever it takes there's a brooch an
heirloom of sorts
we had agreed to give it to them as a
gesture of good will
carrying the broach was way laid by the
withered
broach was lost
exactly oh i hope you'd volunteer of
course our volunteer took the north
so check the weather anything for you
anything for you go and reclaim it but
then
bring it back here
find us keep the situation at that point
i love how the tech said at this point
but this vo said at that point
i mean it doesn't matter but look at you
over here being bright as hell love it
uh any connection issues nope
i'm gonna play when i get off work in
four hours good luck with the cues
i will pray for you
you know thoughts thoughts and prayers
and you get off work in four hours i
said i am fully expecting as soon as i
disconnect to like
barely be able to get back in later but
we'll see
where do i have to go where do i have to
go still in town yes
oh
listen to me
in the youtube chat talking about jeff
bezos is the end boss guys
oh man
people of youtube and twitch
we're in for it at the end of the game
how's frame rate frame rate seems like
it's fine for me
um gpu that i'm using is uh nvidia 2060
i don't remember
how to put on a show
so like right now it looks like i'm
getting
around oh well now it just went up to
60. it's it's moving around but i'm up
now i'm close to 70. if you can see that
in that corner up there
it's moving around a decent a decent bit
but
you know i also have on
uh
obs so that might be doing a little bit
to it as well
get that out there we go
yeah as you can see everything is on
high i'm not gonna go to very high
at least not right now
but yeah with my 2060 it is running just
fine on high
and
i'll experiment with anything else
afterwards
hello i've been thinking about the
threat of corruption
one thing that can at least give us some
comfort is that it will have to overrun
ever fall before it gets to our doorstep
yeah so like they're saying in the chat
yeah some some of the queues some of the
servers are well over
like 25 000. yeah so
like i said thoughts and prayers
maybe do like me and pick a server that
isn't crazy
see you
well if it's fairly optimized i think
it's a buy for me hey man yeah i think
it seems like it for me it is running
just fine especially with all of the
people trying to get in all of the
people playing for it to be launch day
i'm having no crazy issues
sneeze there
um server
i am playing on
what's it called
i was just i just said it to someone not
too long ago
uh
tepan
tampan
i don't remember
would you recommend this game i'm just
gonna say i'm having a good time with it
why is the game called new world because
you are in a
new world it's not
new new it's new to you it's been around
eterna has been around for a thousand
years um
but
it's a supernatural island that's still
super fresh to so many people because so
many people get here and they become
corrupted or they become the lost
um
so for the people that do survive here
you know and are trying to fight back
against the corrupted it's still such a
a new world that they're trying to like
really just like cultivate and make
their own
um
so that's where i get the name from but
if there's something the devs said
about the name
let me know
does it support controller i don't know
but i've seen plenty of people in the
chat say it does
but for the sake of experimentation i
have an 8bitdo
controller right here
so let's pop this guy in
confirmed it does
support controller
i don't know
what
any button does
because i still see down there that like
q is
my moves and stuff
but like i'm blocking
with like
left bumper
attacking with right
trigger
left trigger is doing nothing i can go
prone by clicking in
d-pad is doing nothing
dodging with a
nothing at b
putting away my weapons with y
x is doing nothing so yeah i don't know
why you would want to play this with a
controller honestly
but there you go you can move around and
attack and stuff with it but it looks
like you're still
gonna need a keyboard
and a mouse for
a lot of other stuff like special
abilities and going into menus and all
of that stuff but
looks like controller is supported
if you want to fight with that
type of way of playing
is there dual wield in the end or was it
a scam ah
not sure i don't
i don't think i can do a wheel
i haven't tried
yeah like
no i probably you probably can't
it's interesting i wonder if that's like
something that comes in later
um
is it a good game if you hate pvp i'm
not a pvp fan
and
it looks like it's gonna be just fine
for me with um
the options the p even just the pve
options and stuff like that it seems
like it's gonna be fine even with the
faction like there is
pve and then pve pvp missions and
they're separate
and you have to specifically flag
yourself for pvp so you can walk around
anywhere on flags for pvp and never be
bothered
um which is probably what i'll end up
being most of the time
so i think it's probably a
friendly game for people who hate pvp
thanks for answering those questions for
me john
yeah pvp with controller
can't can't picture it
just like
walking around with controller just then
and having an enemy run at me i was just
kind of thinking to myself if he comes
to attack me i'm not ready
for this dude at all
can i get up up there no i don't need to
go up there i probably just need to be
in this town
we are running towards the end though it
looks like we've been live for almost
two hours so we'll cap this off at two
hours
[Music]
so that i can get back
to making some
game spot video goodness for you
and eat some lunch
running animation looks a little comical
a little bit
just a little
it's not horrible
this is the walking animation though i
feel like the walking animation looks a
little weirder
if you use controller join covenant
first rule of any mmo launch pick a low
server
that's what i did sage that's what i did
and i got in
right away
like things probably have changed now
and
it was either medium or high population
but
the weight was nothing it said zero when
i initially picked it but by the time i
picked like made my character
there was only one person in front of me
and it was very quick
i was in very fast
um but i know other people really want
to play on specific servers and that's
completely fine but just know it might
come with a weight
thank you for sharing sir you're welcome
uh let's go to this one first
[Music]
looks like the corruption in kenner wow
it does you're right i haven't played
that yet but
i was pretty hyped for it so i was
watching coverage of it for a while but
leading up to launching yeah that does
look like the
corruption in canada
so many comparisons to different games
and
now you have
one that's not even an mmo being thrown
in there but you're totally right
there's just so much coming out right
now i don't know when i'm gonna get to
kind of took a back seat i thought i
would play kenna instead of death loop
and then the reviews got me hyped to try
death loop and then i fell in love with
death lube
and now i'm into this
and then hot wheels is dropping and then
after that far cry's dropping and i want
to put a bunch of time into far cry
so i don't know when i get to kind of
just gonna have to still in the
background for a little while
relax
eat some food nope
all right so we're gonna run to this
place
we're gonna get this
thing we're gonna free this corruption
right here
and we'll see how much time we have left
before we have to do the last one
i want to say
the last stream this is the
quest i left off on as well
because i remember getting lost on my
way to it
okay so let's see if we can
do this other one really quick we'll
recall to the end
and then
we will wrap it up
oh look at this syndicate guy
loser
all right
right around the corner switch by
actually let's just hold our musket
giving it no attention let's give it a
little love
you know there's no one to
shoot with it over here
[Applause]
corruption nodule
i've been waiting for three hours now
i'm still on cue
stay strong
stay strong
you'll be in in no time
new world said you can switch your
character to any server within two weeks
that's good to know didn't know that
thank you for that forever faded thank
you thank you thank you
i think i'll stay on the server i'm on
but thank you for that info
all right
it is way over here let's recall to the
in
yep
do our teleport thingy thing
turn in this quest
and then we out
are the queue times bad
they really are for some of the servers
they really are
depending on where you want to be
my advice to you is when you're looking
at the worlds maybe click on the you
know to sort it by
q time or you know cue
size
and maybe don't go for the one that's in
like the high
thousands
stay away from that
he returned with good tidings i just
about all the bad luck i can take
i destroyed him for you wonder why she's
not talking now
i suppose that's a relief then i feel
sorry for the other settlements if they
don't have someone like you around you
should consider buying a home here in
the bluffs i'll make it easier it'll
make it easier for you to return and
head out again
i'm heading out again
i'm afraid so
call that old man who knew about the
corruption he's been sighted fishing at
the eastern river it's a dangerous
journey but he might know something talk
to the inky before you go they need a
faber favor down south as well
boom
well i don't remember talking to me
about buying a house can i buy a house
now too
interesting all right let's open this up
sweet
oh nice ones what
nice damage interesting
cool i'm not like
going to do
stuff with magic i don't think but
yeah that's cool
all right
[Music]
so
there we have it
launch day new world thanks for joining
me
this has been
a blast i'm glad i'm glad the game is
out i'm glad i gave it a chance
and uh
yeah i'm glad i could share the the
energy or the energy i just read the big
pepe energy in the chat i'm glad i could
share this information um with everyone
in the chat who wanted to know
things about the game thanks for all the
people who helped me out and who helped
each other out in the chat with
answering questions about the game
um
yeah
like i said before thoughts and prayers
to everybody who is trying to get in
um
i'm scared to log out because i probably
will have a long queue time to get back
in but
it is what it is
launch day growing pains
so thanks again for watching make sure
you're subbed to gamespot
if you're not on youtube because we're
gonna keep rolling out some new world
coverage
probably starring ya boy
um and also follow me on twitter so that
you know maybe you miss and upload maybe
youtube is hiding one of our videos from
you
i'll tweet it out you can you can see
some of my tweets and and get the latest
game spot videos from me as well so
thanks again for watching
we're out of here say goodbye
for now